we finally have some leaked benchmarks
for the new m1 ipad pro
and to be completely honest they have
blown me away
because we were expecting there to be
some pretty big thermal throttling
issues
due to the super thin size and the new
ultra bright xdr display
so what i'm going to be doing is
analyzing those leaked benchmarks to try
to figure out
how much thermal throttling there is
compared to an m1 mac
and to see which people are going to be
impacted and along with that
help you decide if you should pull the
trigger and upgrade to the new ipad pro
right now and by the way we've already
ordered both the 11 inch and 12.9 inch
models
and we're gonna be doing a full
comparison between the two and between
the older ipad pros
so definitely subscribe right now so you
guys don't miss out
and with that you guys can help us reach
our goal of 1 million subscribers before
the end of the year
we would really appreciate it now before
i get into those leaked benchmarks i
want to say that we were actually
wrong about our performance of the m1
ipad pro in our very first
video the day after the spring loaded
event and it wasn't just
us it also seems like apple may have
understated it
just like they did with the m1 max in
terms of multi-core performance in
geekbench
we estimated that the ipad pro would
score around 7042 points
which is actually pretty good
considering the fact that the previous
ipad pro scored only around 4
700 points so that is a huge improvement
and in terms of graphics performance we
predicted that it would score around
16 855 points due to thermal throttling
because the ipad is obviously much
thinner than the macbook
air but wait until you see these leaks
because they are
incredible so let's get right into it
starting off with the cpu performance
the single core score is basically
identical
to what you'd get in the macbook air
which of course
was expected since single core tasks
don't typically cause
thermal throttling and this means that
everything from using the ui
and basic web browsing and simple apps
is gonna be extremely snappy
better than it's ever been before it's
going to be just flawless now getting
into the multi-core performance
the leaked score is actually around 300
points higher
than our estimate which isn't too far
off
and it is awesome because it shows that
the cooling system is
killing it so far at least on the cpu
side
and honestly this level of performance
is overkill for basically
every single app on the ios app store
because the previous ipad pro
already ran everything without any
issues whatsoever
so the big question is this why would
you need to have
so much power in your ipad pro and there
are actually a few really good reasons
well first you obviously would like to
have a future-proof device
with as much performance as possible if
you're spending
this much money which is what we've
already said about the new m1 ipad pro
in our previous video
but second i have a good feeling that
apple is going to be bringing
professional mac apps to the ipad pro
including final cut
logic pro and xcode which is exactly
what john prosser leaked last year
so those apps will definitely take full
advantage of the m1 chip
and that's why this change is so great
for the ipad pro
now moving on to graphics performance
this is where we were really wrong with
our prediction
of 16 855 points which was also
calculated based on apple's loose
multipliers
we were so far off from that that i'm
honestly shocked that apple pulled this
off
this new m1 ipad pro actually scored as
high as
21 300 points in metal
that is over 4 000 more than i thought
it would
and almost double compared to the
previous a12z ipad pro
which is mind blowing so it is shocking
that this ipad pro would have more
graphics performance than the base
macbook air
which of course uses a 7 core bin
version of the gpu
but it's also thicker and larger overall
compared to the super thin device
now if we compare that to the 8 core
version
like in the m1 macbook pro the ipad pro
is only about 700 points lower which is
really hard to believe
because this ipad pro obviously doesn't
have a fan
and once again it is super thin now i
know that a lot of you guys are gonna
say that geekbench
doesn't matter at all in terms of
thermal throttling but it actually has
in the past for apple devices so let me
prove it to you
the a14 chip in the latest iphone 12
scores around 9000 points in the metal
graphics test
but that same exact a14 chip in the ipad
air
actually scores as high as 12 000 points
so this shows that the iphone is losing
about 25 percent of its potential peak
performance
just because it's being intentionally
throttled by apple and we actually
proved that the iphone
does have thermal throttling issues by
playing games like gentian impact
while at 80 brightness the iphone
started to heat up and the display
dimmed so bad that it was hard to see
all of the details going
on in the game while on the other hand
the new oneplus 9 pro had no dimming
issues whatsoever
because of its new vapor chamber cooling
so the point that i'm trying to make
is that if the m1 ipad pro suffered from
massive thermal throttling issues
apple would have intentionally slowed it
down like they did with the iphone
but it's literally barely slower than
the m1 macbook pro
which is the best news we could have
received from these leaks
however these leaked benchmarks don't
tell us the full story for a couple of
different reasons
first off every single one of the leaked
m1 ipad pro submissions
on the geekbench website has 16
gigabytes of ram
which actually does impact the score now
not by
that much but it definitely does which
we've actually proved in an imac ram
video we did last year
on top of that what if all of these
leaked benchmarks on the website are
specifically from the 12.9 inch ipad pro
since that's the model apple wants
reviewers to get into their hands
and show off to the people so what if
the 11 inch model
actually scores worse than what we're
seeing in these leaks
if you think about it the 12.9 inch
model is physically larger and actually
thicker than the 11 inch model so
probably does a bit better at cooling
because there's more room for heat to
dissipate
but of course that's something that we
won't find out until we actually get
them in our hands
so be sure to subscribe because we'll be
doing a full comparison
between the two to find out and also
between the eight gigabyte and 16
gigabyte ram versions as well
now the last thing that i want to
mention is that geekbench doesn't tell
the full story
because it does run quicker than other
benchmarks so the chip doesn't have
as long to heat up so in very long and
heavy tasks that will heat up the m1
chip
you should probably expect thermal
throttling because the m1 macbook air
thermal throttles
in cinebench are 23 when compared to the
macbook pro
and i would say it's tasks that run
longer than five minutes for example
video exports or photo exports
however not many people are gonna be
using it for those kind of tasks
and with that this m1 chip is so
powerful
that what if it's able to complete most
productivity tasks
before the chip even has a chance to
heat up and start thermal throttling
which is what we've actually seen with
our m1 macbook air
in a variety of tests even exporting a
bunch of
raw 42 megapixel images that are color
graded
and it gets done pretty much as fast as
the macbook pro and of course
that is the ultimate goal get it done
quickly and efficiently
but based on these leaked benchmarks i'm
even more confident now
that this ipad pro is going to be future
proof because of its killer performance
and the new thunderbolt port on top of
that that one chip comes with apple's
new 16 core neural engine
which is gonna absolutely kill it for
machine learning
and ai based applications compared to
older ipads and even compared to older
macs
and windows computers for example we
tested out the new photoshop
which is optimized for the m1 chip their
new super resolution tool
and it literally took 13 seconds
compared to over 10 minutes
on our new intel laptop which is insane
and with this new chip more applications
are going to be making use
of that crazy capability so if we look
at a four year old 10 and a half inch
ipad pro with that a10x fusion chip
the new ipad pro is almost three times
faster in terms of graphics performance
which is insane
and that doesn't even count this new
machine learning and in terms of
multi-core performance it is literally
over three times faster than that 10.5
inch ipad pro
so anyone with an ipad that doesn't come
with an 812x or a12z chip
is going to see a huge difference in
performance
but honestly if you already have a 2018
or 2020 ipad pro you're probably not
going to notice
that big of a difference at least at
launch unless you're planning to
absolutely push it to its limits so even
though the m1 ipad pro
is enticing don't feel pressure to buy
yet because you might not notice that
big of a difference coming from the
recent models
and like i said in my last ipad video
when was the last time that you
complained
about your current ipad pro being too
slow but there you guys go
if you disagree with my conclusions on
the performance comment your thoughts
down below
but if you agree click that circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
one
check out one of the great videos over
there thank you guys for watching this
has been max and i will see you
in the next video